this video is kindly sponsored by ag-1
by athletic greens the simple way to
better nutrition
hey 42 here in 2017 oxfam reported that
the eight richest men on earth owned the
same wealth as the poorest half
of the world's population put together
that's that highlights something a
little bit hard
most of us like to think of our society
as a meritocracy
that the more skillful intelligent and
hardworking we are the more successful
we'll be
but broadly speaking talent is normally
distributed across the population
wealth on the other hand
very much isn't
it's a reasonable bet that the eight
richest men on the planet are all
extremely capable but it's hard to
imagine they have the skills to match
the 3.5 billion poorest people combined
so
what's going on
to find out let's take a look at the man
who topped the rich list when oxfam
released that eye-opening stat
bill gates
ag-1 by athletic greens is an
essentialist nutrition company that has
created a movement around simplifying
your health routine and it's not just
for athletes it's for anybody that wants
to take ownership of their health ag-1
is also giving my community an immune
supporting free one-year supply of
vitamin d
as well as five free travel packs with
your first purchase but more on that
later there's no reason that looking
after yourself should be difficult
that's why ag-1 has made it super easy
in fact one of their convenient daily
servings is packed with 75 vitamins
minerals whole food sourced superfoods
probiotics and adaptogens for me however
it was my focus where i really noticed a
difference i'm so busy every day with
many different projects competing for my
time and i always find it really hard to
focus on one thing but after trying g1 i
feel constantly locked in on my goals
and my productivity has definitely
increased
did i mention it also tastes really good
which is quite a surprise considering
how many nutritional goodies are packed
into it so if you're looking for a
maintainable way to fill the nutritional
gaps in your diet then go to the link in
the description now to get a year's
supply of vitamin d3k2
and five travel packs for free with your
first purchase this is a game changer
for supporting your immune system ag-1
provides your body with everything it
needs for optimal performance every
single day
in 2017 gates had a personal wealth just
shy of 90 billion dollars
it's hard to put that into perspective
on a human scale so for reference 90
billion dollars is roughly the gdp of
ethiopia
a country with a population of over 100
million people
or if you prefer it was more than 0.1
of the gdp of our entire planet at the
time
so
did bill gates attain this frankly
ridiculous fortune thanks to his
remarkable talents or through some other
means well let's start with the talent
part bill gates is an extremely smart
guy actually smart doesn't really cover
it his iq is estimated to be around 160.
that's about the same as einstein's
comfortably genius territory gates is
almost famous for being an almost
inhumanly hard worker by some accounts
he will clock up to 120 hours in the
office per week in the early days of
microsoft
enough to send tim ferriss into cardiac
arrest
on the surface it sounds like an open
and shut case bill gates was and
probably still is a hard-working genius
so the fact he became unimaginably
successful
is no fluke
and that's absolutely true the problem
is
it isn't the whole truth
you see there was another factor at play
that helped bill gates achieve his
phenomenal success
he was
absurdly lucky
let's get the obvious bits of luck out
of the way first he was born in one of
the most prosperous countries on earth
the usa
his parents were wealthy and successful
and they had enough spare cash lying
around to send him to an elite private
school by the name of lakeside still
ranked as one of the best private high
schools in the us to this day
that's about a good a start in life as
any human could hope to have
and there's more the year after gates
enrolled at lakeside the school started
a club offering students remote access
to a powerful mainframe computer that
might not sound like a big deal but this
was 1968
when computer access
essentially didn't exist in high schools
and home pcs hadn't even been invented
yet
lakeside was quite literally
one of the only schools in the world
giving it students access to a powerful
computer at the time which meant bill
gates had the opportunity to learn to
code younger than almost anyone in
history before him
one of the other lucky ones given that
opportunity was paul allen one of
gates's classmates at lakeside and the
man who he would go on to found
microsoft with
bill gates is a brilliant guy there's no
disputing that
but he isn't unique that 160 iq of his
yeah around 0.03 of the population can
match that
that's over 2 million people worldwide
who are
on paper just as intelligent as he is
and considering that sample size some
will inevitably be just as driven and
hardworking as he was too the reason
you've never heard of them whilst bill
gates is one of the richest men in
history
it's nothing to do with skill talent
or hard work
just
plain old luck
or at least
chance
luck is a bit like money it doesn't seem
all that important
until it runs out
but the idea that luck plays a big role
in our lives
is surprisingly controversial
most successful people even the lucky
ones
work pretty hard and it's never nice to
hear that your achievements are as much
to look as your grit and determination
i'm not trying to say that talent and
hard work count for nothing they count
for a hell of a lot
hard work especially
but there's no guessing around it
hidden dice rolls from the great big
random number generator in the sky
have a huge impact on how all of our
lives turn out
bill gates is an example of what can
happen in a perfect talent look storm
he was the right person in the right
place at the right time in history
and that was enough to make him the
richest man alive
had his parents chosen any other school
in the us
he would have been deprived of both his
edge and his business partner
and microsoft would never have happened
that isn't just an opinion by the way
gates has said so himself on more than
one occasion
of course no microsoft doesn't mean his
life would have ended in failure but it
might well have made tens of billions of
dollars difference in terms of his net
worth
all from a seemingly inconsequential
decision like
which school he went to
think of life as being a bit like an
old-school rpg
to begin with your character gets
assigned a bunch of random
characteristics like race and bass
attributes
you have no control over these and they
may either help you or hinder you when
the game begins
your childhood is basically the tutorial
you get the chance to improve some of
your stats and specialize in a couple of
skill trees unfortunately most of us
don't really know how the game works at
this point so we just mess around a bit
and end up under-leveled
towards the end of the tutorial you'll
be asked to pick your character's class
mage rogue accountant
and then
the game starts for real
but no two game worlds are the same
some people are dumped in the middle of
a ridiculously difficult region
surrounded by hordes of high-level
enemies
whilst others have unlimited resources
in their inventory and a bunch of
powerful npcs to protect them being
blessed with good stats resources and
favorable in-game events doesn't
guarantee you'll win
over it just makes things a hell of a
lot easier
it's worth pointing out that being lucky
in life doesn't have to be some profound
sliding doors coincidence like a maths
genius attending one of the only schools
in the u.s with access to a computer
most of the time
it's much simpler than that
if what i told you about bill gates
sounded familiar
it may well be that you've read outliers
by malcolm gladwell where his story is
covered in some detail if you have
you'll already be familiar with
something called the relative age effect
where success in various fields is
influenced by something as seemingly
unimportant
as which month of the year you're born
in
the concept is pretty simple children
born just after the cut-off date for any
given activity
be it starting school or joining a
sports team have a big advantage over
those born just before the cut-off date
that's because they're always the oldest
in any given cohort meaning they're just
that bit more physically and
intellectually developed than their
peers
in outliers gladwell illustrates the
power of the relative age effect by
talking about ice hockey but since that
one's been done to death i've found a
more british example football if you're
watching from across the ponds that suck
no
no i'm sorry
i can't do it
intuitively it feels like football
should be a strict meritocracy with the
better players rising to the top and
going on to have the most successful
careers
if that were truly the case
the month in which a top player was born
should be irrelevant
we'd see a random array of birth dates
spread throughout the year amongst
professionals
but
we don't see that
in fact it isn't even close of the 30
most capped england players of all time
six were born in september that's 20
or roughly 2.5 times what we should see
if the month in which you were born had
no impact on your chances of playing for
england
by the way the significance of september
is that that's the month school starts
in the uk
meaning kids born in september are
always the oldest in their school year
so have a guess how many of the 30 most
capped england footballers of all time
were born in august making them the
youngest kids in the year during their
school days let me tell you
it's zero
not
one
okay i know what you're thinking this is
a small sample so maybe that's just some
kind of anomaly
but listen to this none of the 30 most
capped england footballers of all time
were born in july either
and only one was born in june
that means six times as many of
england's 30 most capped players were
born in september than in june july and
august
combined to put that another way
something as utterly random as the month
you're born has a profound impact on
your chances of becoming an england
footballing legend
at first it might not be entirely
obvious why the relative age effect has
such a huge impact
after all as children get older a
difference of 11 or 12 months in age
becomes less important and eventually
irrelevant
the problem is by then
it's already too late
the good footballers in each school year
are identified young when being the
oldest offers them a huge physical
advantage
those players are then far more likely
to find themselves as part of school or
local teams as they grow up and so they
play more regularly receive more praise
and get more coaching
as a result instead of the younger
players catching up over time as their
age becomes less of a factor
they actually fall further behind
by the way that lone june birthday
amongst england's 30 most capped
footballers
belongs to frank lampard
and whilst he may have been born in an
unlucky month that bad luck was wiped
clean off the slate by an even bigger
slice of good luck that surely gave his
career a huge boost
his father frank lampard senior
played football for england too
fittingly enough frank lampard senior
was born on the 20th of september
unsurprisingly the relative age effect
has a big impact in academia too
and for exactly the same reasons in 2012
students with autumn birthdays were 25
percent more likely to be accepted at
the uk's most prestigious universities
oxford and cambridge than students with
summer birthdays
[Music]
predictably perhaps the most important
look factor in most of our lives
comes from the socioeconomic situation
we're born into in the u.s s.a.t scores
are heavily correlated with family
income with a 2015 analysis finding that
average sat scores were lowest amongst
families earning under 20 000 a year and
highest amongst families making over two
hundred thousand dollars a year now you
might assume those numbers simply imply
children from high income families are
on average more intelligent
than those from low income families
but the evidence doesn't back that up
according to a 2019 study conducted in
the us
recently discovered genetic markers for
academic ability
are fairly evenly distributed across the
population
regardless of family wealth
and yet the least academically gifted
children from high income families are
more likely to attain a university
degree than the most academically gifted
children from low-income families just
think about what that means for a second
if you want to go to university it's
quite literally better to be rich than
to be clever
up until this point we've been looking
at whether talent or luck determines
success
but the thing is that question is
actually kind of flawed according to the
cambridge english dictionary look is
defined as success or failure apparently
brought about by chance rather than
through one's own actions and when you
think about it a big slice of your own
level of talent
comes from things that are entirely
outside of your control take
intelligence for example it's generally
thought that iq is mostly a product of
your genes and the environment you grew
up in two things you have essentially no
control over which means if you happen
to have been born with an above average
dose of talent
that in itself is pretty lucky and you
weren't any more deserving of success
than someone who got less lucky than you
in the innate talents department it's
also worth mentioning that success is
not a cinnamon for wealthy even if
that's how most people think these days
success can and should mean different
things to different people
and money is only one small part of it
earlier in this video i compared life to
an rpg
but maybe it's better to think of it as
a bit like a lottery only each of us
starts out with a different number of
tickets
anyone lucky enough to be born to
affluent loving parents and given a
quality education starts out life with a
lot of lottery tickets to their name
whilst people who get a rough start in
life hardly have any
maybe none at all
as depressing a concept as that is
no matter your starting point in life
you can always get more tickets by
working hard studying gaining new skills
and meeting new people it's no guarantee
you'll eventually hit the success
jackpot
but it certainly increases your odds
thanks for watching
good news you can now pre-order my new
book bread and circuses what did the
romans ever do for us
it's a wild and witty journey for a
thousand years of unexpected roman
history
told in a refreshing way and packed full
of incredible and unbelievable stories
copies are selling out fast so pre-order
yours today to lock it in thank you